next terry pinker discusses his
biography of georg wilhelm friedrich
hagel a german philosopher who lived in
the time of beethoven and thomas
jefferson among hegel's works are
phenomenology of spirit and philosophy
of right
terry pinker discusses hegel's life his
ideas and his influence on today's
political thinkers
his comments are about 45 minutes
welcome to bridge street books i'm
phillip levy the owner and we're we're
here to celebrate the publication of
hegel a biography by terry pinkert
professor of georgetown university
professor pinkert and his wife susan
pinkert a dean of the school of foreign
service have been longtime friends and
customers of bridge street books so
we're particularly pleased to host the
event tonight
hegel a biography published by cambridge
university press is that rare
combination of historical and
philosophical depth with lively and
engaging writing professor pinkerts
hegel is a lucid and entertaining
portrait of the man in his time
the work in its context and the
revolutions and counter revolutions
which hegel's work created
these are ideas and events which
continue to shape contemporary society
though i'll admit you'll have to ask
professor pinkert for the details
i would just like to mention that this
newly released book has already received
rave reviews from publishers weekly
which called it a narrative of operatic
scope
and the boston book review which ended
its review by stating by now it's clear
that profes that professor pinkert
offers the most rounded richly filled
out picture of hagel as both philosopher
and man
that we have ever had in english this
will quickly become the standard
biography of hegel and richly deserves
to do so in an age of fine hegel
scholarship this is a towering
achievement professor pinker
thank you very much um just a couple of
words of what led me to do this at first
i of course have been interested in
hegel really for quite a while here um
can you can people hear me here
okay
okay
i've been interested in hegel really for
quite a while here and one of the things
that of course first drew me to hagel's
thought was hegel's uncompromising
modernity hegel was in many ways
the first of a long line of people to
try and think through and understand
what it really meant to live
in the modern world what it meant to
live in a world where all the old
certainties had collapsed and
that from now on we were as individuals
and as collectives
performing without a net those in hezego
like to say in this modern world
we're free sailing there's nothing above
us and nothing below us that
the old props that had held us up for so
many years
the reliance on tradition
or the reliance on some form of sacred
text
or the reliance on some unambiguous
conception of what it meant to be
natural
or some particular shared religion like
christendom
had simply vanished as having any kind
of binding and authoritative force
for ourselves that these old props had
as it were
gradually and slowly rotted away from
underneath us
so hegel is this great modernist trying
to think about what it really meant to
live a life with nothing above you and
nothing below you where we are each
individually and collectively making it
up as we go along here offered a
fascinating philosophical topic for me
to think about but as the years wore on
of course i began to wonder a little bit
more about who exactly hegel was
especially given the controversies that
have always surrounded hegel's life
by and large the picture of hegel that
has been bequeathed to us over the years
is of a very stuffy
somewhat pompous arrogant
very conservative reactionary fellow who
for whatever brilliance he may have had
was an unpleasant individual
that didn't really fit well that picture
of hagel the person didn't really fit
well with the hegel of course that i had
been encountering in the text and have
been teaching now for almost 20 years
when i started out doing the biography i
was of course curious to see exactly how
hegel's life and his thought would
really interact with each other and i
was really quite surprised to find
that hagel the person turned out to be
a much more fascinating and interesting
character than even i could have given
him credit for
he was a complex fellow he was certainly
no saint
but he was not the reactionary he was
not the stuffed shirt he was not the
arrogant pompous individual that he has
usually been made out to be
here
just a little bit about hegel's life and
i'd like just to talk just to give you
some more or less exemplary passages
that may
may in some sense break up the old and
established picture of hegel that we
have i won't talk too much right now
about the philosophy of this
my question in this book who was hegel
hegel was first of all he was the son of
a minor level functionary in stuttgart
there were great problems in hegel's
family his father quite clearly sided
with his younger brother hagel and his
sister quite clearly sided with the
mother there were immense tensions when
his mother died at the age of 11
and of the same disease that hegel had
at the time what was described as gall
fever whatever that may have been at the
time
hegel developed a kind of uh complex
about this of course being the one who
survived the disease and developed a
stutter for the rest of his life
he felt in many ways quite alienated
from his family in all his letters he
rarely rarely talks about his father but
he often talks about his mother
his mother wanted him to be a pastor
hagel didn't particularly want to be a
pastor but nonetheless he was sent off
to
the university in tubingen in the
seminary there to study to become a
lutheran pastor and while there
this young man who by the way had
graduated at the top of his class in his
german high school the gymnasium there
who graduated the top of his class
quickly became a rather solemn rebel
he ended up rooming with two other young
men who had also been destined to become
lutheran pastors
friedrich herlin
who was later become arguably the
greatest german poet of the 19th century
and probably one of the greatest poets
in the german language ever
and friedrich schelling who also in
addition to hegel became one of the
great philosophers and thinkers of the
19th century
they spent about five years together
during those five years they formed a
passionate love for the french
revolution
shelling translated the marseilles
they had many friends who participated
in it one of their other roommates a man
named what vetsel wetzel uh in fact
joined the french army rather than
taking his final exams at the university
joined the french armies fought against
the germans came back took the exams
went back and joined the french armies
and then realized it was probably not
wise to come back a third time
and instead moved to paris where he
became a leading industrialist and in
fact a manufacturer of pianos
another fellow from the same seminary a
man named reichardt actually went to
paris joined the revolution
and replaced talleyrand as friends as
france's foreign minister in the
geranding government so there was lots
of inspirational things going on at the
time
on getting out of the university hegel
of course didn't himself
do too well but the first picture i
think we can get of hagel is hegel is a
young man hegel as a student at the
university his nickname among his
friends herloon and shelly in fact all
his friends there was the old man the
reason he was called the old man was
because he was in fact very very
studious this of course fits the picture
of perhaps hegel the bookworm but and
this will let you know that university
life perhaps has not changed a whole lot
in the last couple of hundred years
um
toy matt hegel's in the section of the
book where i'm talking about hagel's
reading matter and the book clubs he
belonged to in the discussion groups
i come to this point say but hegel's
mind was not completely absorbed
in such abstruse matters
he remained a gregarious soul and like
many students before and since he and
his fellow students reacted to the
strictness of their academic environment
by forming bonds of camaraderie with
each other
hegel loved to play cards something he
appreciated as a schoolboy and stuttgart
and throughout the rest of his life
discuss issues with friends
and engage in friendly drinking bouts at
the mini pubs around tubingen
these escapades along with hegel's
continuous cutting of lectures and his
continual oversleeping of his classes
did not go unnoticed by the proctors and
the records show hegel being cited
several times for such breaches of the
rules
the records also show him being thrown
into the student jail for a couple of
hours in 1791
his infraction had to do with his having
ridden on horseback without permission
with a couple of friends to a
neighboring village and then having
arrived back at the seminary too late
the reason he gave was that the horse
belonging to one of his friends a
frenchman studying at the seminary
becomes sick
an eagle and another friend mr fink red
refused to ride back without him
the result of hegel's disobedience to
the rules was some mandatory time spent
in the kartzer the student jail at
chubigan
and as is often the case with such
students hegel also became fond of
frequenting the taverns with his friends
his condition on returning to the
seminary late one night prompted one of
the older porters at the seminary gates
to exclaim
oh hegel you're going to drink away what
little intellect you have left
on yet another occasion when the
reporter saint porter i assume that
managed him with hegel you're going to
drink yourself to death hagel replied
surely in the slightly slurred and
blurry tone that he had just been out
for a little refreshment
uh
his sister remembered hagel in his
student days as a rather jovial sword
who loved both the dance and to visit
the ladies
so it was clear that this model student
at least was no stuff shirt completely
even when he was the old man in tubingen
on graduating hegel went off to become a
house tutor in barron he went off with
great dreams of becoming a private
writer perhaps you know in some instance
writing popular pieces for the german
press instigating a new political moral
and social reform along the lines of the
french revolution instead he found
himself as a house tutor
and a rather boring place for one of the
most reactionary families in all of
baron
and he never had any time to himself he
became actually fairly depressed about
all this here
uh he ended up going over to another
friend's house all the time where they
would play the piano and sing
freddy scherner guccifunken in one of
the pre-beethoven settings here
his very first publication by the way
appeared during this period it was a
translation of a french pamphlet
translated into german
that was attacking the ruling
german-speaking berenice oligarchy which
was led by the family for whom he was a
house tutor
he also had a little commentary on it
where he looked to the example of the
american revolution and said you know
something similar should happen in
barron so there was hegel the young
house tutor translating revolutionary
pamphlets right in the house of the
people that he was working for while
singing frederickson or grunken
on the piano at his friend's house
nonetheless he was pretty depressed
here
his friend herlene had gone on to a
slightly better career herlon was living
in frankfurt at the time as a tutor to a
very wealthy family the gantard family
in frankfurt
he had also become a published poet and
was already attracting quite a lot of
recognition for his early poetry
his other roommate shelling had gone on
to stage a rather meteoric rise and
become
in his twenties a famous philosophical
celebrity throughout germany whereas
hegel was stuck in baron still being a
house tutor and writing these kind of
despairing letters to his friends about
how things weren't going quite as he had
hoped they would have gone
the friendship
with the poet hurley especially was to
prove very lasting and really
epical for hegel um
and talking about hegel's depression at
one point in the book i mentioned that
that in his letters to both sheldon and
herolyn hegel's depressed mood was
evident
seeking to help his old friend
herlolyn began immediately looking for a
position for hegel and frankfurt
discovering that a prosperous wine
merchant goggle was seeking a house
tutor for his children
herolyn managed to maneuver an offer of
the job to hegel he announced this
triumphantly to hegel the working
conditions he told him are really quite
good and
you will drink very good rhine wine or
french wine at the table you will live
at one of the most beautiful houses in
frankfurt on one of the most beautiful
squares in the city rustmark plotz
his employers the goggle family are
hurdled and assured him quite sociable
free of pretension and prejudice who
prefer not to associate with frankfurt
society folk with their stiff ways and
poverty of heart and spirit
and of course best of all the position
is in frankfurt a bustling commercial
center
indeed hurling assured hegel by next
spring you'll once again become the old
man
the deep emotion hurtling felt about
being able to unite with his old friend
was only too evident i am he told hegel
a man who has remained faithful to you
in heart memory and spirit despite
rather variegated transformations in his
situation and character who will be your
friend more deeply and warmly than ever
who will freely and willingly share
every moment of life with you whose
situation lacks nothing but you to
complete its happiness i truly need you
dear friend and i believe you will be
capable of needing me as well
herlon warmly concluded
i still have much to tell you but you're
coming here must be the preface to a
long
long interesting unscholarly book by you
and me
here hagel of course accepted the offer
and immediately went to frankfurt this
became a major turning point in hagel's
life during this period herlin
had who was now becoming more famous as
a poet
was still as operating as a house tutor
for the gantard family the guntards were
very wealthy bankers in frankfurt
the
old the husband jacob gontard was a good
bit older than her olympia but he had
married
a very beautiful woman who was exactly
her lily's age who had high literary
ambitions on her own and he himself was
a bit of a philistine
there was this absolutely gorgeous
looking young poet hanging around the
house and well you can't imagine what
happened
at one point when the french army was
shelling frankfurt in fact jacob gontard
instructed herlolyn to take his wife and
children far away to castle for a month
or two which is about the worst thing
you can do in those circumstances
on returning her lin was fired from his
position although the two lovers
continued to see each other since hagel
was still persona grata and the guntard
household he would be the one who would
make the assassinations for the two to
meet at various places another old
friend from the seminary izak von
sinclair in fact had become the minister
in a neighboring principality herland
was established as a librarian
and he suzette gontard would sometimes
walk with hegel over to
this little town outside of frankfurt
right where herloden and susetta guntard
continued things
here
this came to an end in 1800 here in 1799
hagel's father died and as often happens
with these kinds of things hagel
realized that now
at the age of almost 30 it was finally
time for him to get a life he wasn't
just going to be a house tutor forever
he had not yet published anything except
this unknown pamphlet
here this translation of this french
revolutionary pamphlet which by the way
most people never knew was even written
or published by hegel when he died his
family sold it off as they thought it
was some kind of odd thing he must have
picked up as a student they didn't even
his own wife and children didn't realize
that in fact he had done this here
right think of all the things you don't
know about
about your parents here
in any event hegel and herlin had to
drift apart herlolin went off to
bordeaux for a while
but on returning and learning that
susetta gontard had in fact contracted
both tuberculosis and measles and had
died herlon had a complete mental
breakdown hurdle limb became a
schizophrenic for the rest of his life
he lived until 1843.
he never wrote with one exception he
never wrote again of any kind of major
poetry he lived he had in fact instead
to move in with a nice carpenter in his
family here who agreed to take care take
care of him strangely enough that was a
carpenter who was a great fan of
contemporary poetry and said
sure we'll take care of her alone where
he lived in the city of chewing gum in a
little house on the river then for the
rest of his life
more or less dark raving mad not knowing
who he was going by various identities
and just spending his time in his room
talking to himself
over and over and over again here
hegel's life
didn't get much easier he managed to go
to yana a center of learning at the time
exactly as it was falling apart
using his very slender inheritance that
he had gotten from his father he was
able to support himself for several
years but he was not able to get an
actual paying job at yena as conditions
became worse and napoleonic wars
intensified and the inflation set in and
his meager inheritance began to wear out
more and more and more
in 1806 hagel had no publications
no job
no money
no prospect of a job and the landlady
from whom he was renting his apartment
was pregnant by him
and as napoleon was shelling the town of
yena hegel managed to complete his first
major and most important work the
phenomenology of spirit in a period when
he was immensely depressed and shall we
say had a lot of other things on his
mind
it was there that hegel really
formulated the typical hegelian view of
things that we cannot understand
ourselves outside of our own history
that who we are
has to be understood in terms of who we
had to come to be in light of all this
kind of contingent past and that now is
the time for us to make the most sense
of who exactly we were in this now
free-floating modern world here
despite the initial success of this book
hagel still couldn't get a job and ended
up editing a newspaper in bamberg he was
a newspaper editor for two years editing
a pro napoleonic newspaper
and becoming quite a bon viva around
town is some very touching stories i
think which i won't go into here about
how he took care of all the employees
working for his newspaper
and finally he was able to get a job at
least teaching but this was at a high
school in nuremberg
so in 1808 he and went to nirenberg
to assume position to teach
roughly three to 400 students several
different classes he was in charge of
all philosophical instruction for the
newly reorganized kingdom of bavaria
and he also had to run the entire school
district basically in this area
during this period he completely
resuscitated the uh the gymnasium there
he also wrote and published his book the
science of logic he started working on
the rest of his system to get ready this
encyclopedia philosophical sciences
which was finally published in his last
year in nuremberg in 1817 there and came
out after he moved to heidelberg he also
managed during this period to buck all
the trends
and despite the fact that there was no
money available he managed somehow to
get the money to set up the first
women's school
uh which was head which was in fact not
only
instituted to teach young women all the
way through high school but was in fact
taught by women
a young miss eisler who had applied to
come to the gymnasium where hegel was
teaching and was turned down because she
was female was instead
accepted as the first head and principle
of this gymnasium the gymnasium later
merged with hegel's old gymnasium in
1831.
during this period he married into the
into the nuremberg patricia he married
marie fontoucher
of old outstanding family and it was a
relationship
that as far as we can gather will seem
to be very close and very intimate and
very happy then for the rest of their
lives
this despite the fact that there was a
20-year difference between them
there were of course some glitches along
the way it always happens when you marry
someone 20 years younger than you are
but nonetheless right hegel and his wife
had a happy life they ended up with two
sons and they later took in hegel's
illegitimate son ludwig fischer into
their house after the hegel got his
first professorship at the age of 48.
this was the first paying university job
he had ever had his life was two-thirds
over by that point
uh they moved to heidelberg and then
shortly thereafter hagel got the job he
had wanted the position at the radically
new university of berlin
the university that by and large has
shaped the form of modern universities
that we know today a university
dedicated as its founder put it to
teaching and research to bringing the
best
minds in contact with the best young
minds and somehow creating a kind of
energy and excitement out of that that
would last
the picture that you usually get of
hagel after moving to berlin is that
after he moved to berlin he became very
famous became very stuffy became a
reactionary became the official
philosopher of prussian absolutism as
the old phrase had it
in fact this isn't true immediately on
getting there his student assistant that
he picked a young man named caravay was
arrested interrogated and then banned
from teaching in universities throughout
germany for being too much of a liberal
radical carl va had published some
articles that call for full civil
emancipation of jews for example for
open admissions to all kinds of other
things for the abolition of special
privileges for the aristocracy
for that karavey lost all prospect of
academic employment
hegel then picked another student he
thought this would be a little safer a
man named leopold font-henning an
aristocrat who in fact had been an
officer in the wars against napoleon but
also was in fact a liberal who was
immediately arrested also put in jail
and
for some liberal pampleteering
now this is during the height of the
repression when the prussian government
is looking for absolutely anywhere right
to find these subversives demagogues as
they as it called them
and was throwing a lot of people in jail
and firing a lot of professors from
their jobs for being such subversives
hegel already had two of his students in
jail
a little passage from this
with carol they having been rejected by
the authorities hagel had to make a
second choice for teaching assistant
somewhat defiantly he chose leopold
fonteny
again an aristocrat who had fought the
wars against napoleon as a volunteer
so on and so on here i will skip the
passages about henning's arrest
henry was held for several weeks with a
policeman guarding the door to his
prison cell
during fond henning's imprisonment hagel
did something a bit extraordinary
hey henny's cell had a window facing the
spray river in berlin not far from the
university and not far from hegel's own
apartment
hegel joined his other students on a
skiff and at midnight they all rode up
to the point at which henning's cell
window faced the river and began a
conversation with him in latin so that
it could not be understood by the guards
if they happen to overhear it they
wished to let him know that they were
convinced of his innocence they were
working hard to prove it as the boat
pulled up next to hinny's window close
enough for hagel and henning to shake
hands
hagel aware of the general absurdity of
the situation in which he put himself
uttered in latin in a very mock grave
tone
numerous literally translated now you
surely see me
which provoked no small amount of mirth
among those present
he didn't continue with some vague
generalities in latin the group went
home the students amused and probably a
bit surprised by hegel's ironic
treatment of the situation and all
probably including hegel himself joking
about the matter on the way back
uh hegel's first biographer carl
rosencrantz laconically noted would have
been all too easy for hegel to have been
shot by a zealous prussian watchman and
the history of philosophy would have
been
very much different
here
this wasn't the there were many other
things that occurred like this when his
friend from france victor kuzan was also
arrested and thrown in jail in 1824
hagel very courageously went public on a
letter demanding kazan's immediate
release
there was a lot of problems with this
even hegel's friend said you may be
going too far this time but in fact he
was able to secure kuzan's release
something that
kazan never forgot and in fact dedicated
several books to him kuzan himself later
of course became the founder of the
economy superior a major french
philosopher and a major figure in french
education here
a number of other
um uh
a number of other anecdotes in fact at
one point in 1820 during this period of
great repression hegel took his students
to dresden to see the artworks there
as they were all sitting around the
table in the end where they were all
staying the waiter came over with the
local meisner wine hegel rejected it
instead ordering three bottles of the
most expensive champagne in europe
champagne celery
he poured the champagne around for all
of his students and then said you know
toast and the students of course happily
coughed it all down as students are want
to do finally hegel said now
you do realize what we're drinking to
today don't you and the students said
well no what he said gentlemen to the
14th of july to the storming of the
bastille here
one of the students present was a young
jewish scholar named edward van gaan
edward gonz who later became in fact one
of hagel's closest students and one of
the
major figures in the revitalization of
the jewish community in berlin and in
fact was the person who
wrote the official obituary for hegel
after his death
there was another fellow hegel was great
friends with in berlin a man named
moritz safier who was a jewish humorist
who used to dress outrageously in fact
he wore different colored wigs all the
time you know sometimes blonde sometimes
blue
he was a famous jokester none of the
jokes really come across i think
nowadays but a very funny lot very funny
guy here
hegel is one of his closest friends
sophia in fact used to come over the
hagel household all the time
hegel's friendship with saphir this is
from the book was typical of his dual
life as hegel's son described it
there was a proper bourgeois professor
he also hegel also had a need to hang
out
with swift tongue artists bohemians of
various stripes and figures somewhat on
the margin of things
both hegel and gonz were saphir's
friends and shared many evenings
together with safir
software even embroiled hegel or will
hegel embroiled himself in what turned
out to be a legendary comical incident
among that crowd in berlin
in may 1826 a man named carl shaw came
to berlin
shaw was a high living big spending
grandly eating very rotund dilettante a
passionate devotee of the theater and of
actresses in particular who after
scoring big in the lottery decided that
berlin would be a nice place to indulge
his taste like so many berliners at the
time he was totally smitten with
henrietta's untodd the beautiful chased
singer in the musical stage in the main
berlin theater people even spoke of
zantog fever at the time sontag was also
a friend of a friend of hegel's
sapphire always the debunker was of
course on the other hand forever making
jokes at santos expense in his newspaper
assange announced that she was leaving
berlin for paris a group of admirers
including shaw met at the cafe royal in
berlin the night before her last
performance to plan an homage to her
finally deciding they would litter the
stage with poems written in her honor
immediately upon conclusion the final
performance
saffrey remarked that he too would throw
a poem onto the stage but in honor of
one of the members of the chorus a young
woman of as it were tarnished reputation
shall exploded at this perceived insult
is on top and claiming to defend
zantog's honor against saphir's insults
challenged the fear to a duel which the
fear accepted
the challenge was itself already absurd
shawl whose size was round and grand
even joked that safir tall and very thin
would not make as good a target as him
the duel was set for the next day shawl
and his second showed up safir showed up
alone all waited tensely for safir's
second to appear who after all in berlin
would agree to be the second for that
outrageous jewish humorist
finally a black taxi coach pulled up
bearing software second and outstepped
of all people hegel
all of which suddenly gave the scene as
one observer put it an irresistibly
comical error
from that moment on it was clear that no
duel was going to take place hegel
persuaded shaw he was also one of shaw's
friends to apologize to sapphire and
everything was put back in order
barely in whit had won the day
hegel continued to battle with this he
in 1826 there was a large birthday party
celebration for him which because his
birthday was so close to the kings
made the king very angry and banned the
kingdom personally banned all future
publication about private birthday
parties uh it was in fact uh bad enough
that hagel decided that next year for
his birthday he'd better spend it in
paris so he went to see his good friend
victor kuzan
where once getting there hegel who was a
tremendous francophile and loved paris
he called it the capital the civilized
world he wrote back home to his wife and
said from now on we're speaking french
right at home so on uh he also found
that nonetheless although he
he really liked french food it kind of
got the better of him and he became very
he became ill with indigestion and in
fact ended up eating at a german
restaurant the whole time he was there
here
there is
throughout this of course hegel's
friendships with his two earlier
best friends
sheldon and hurlan always continued to
be in the background sheldon had gone on
to become quite famous but after 1809
had seized publication
although he continued to be a major
figure in german intellectual circles
shelling also became quite upset that
his old roommate had eclipsed him in
fame and he began to grumble to
everybody around about how wrong it was
that hagel had become more famous than
him because after all hegel he said
stole all his ideas from me here
everything he knows he got from me and
he just put it in slightly different
terms you know i knew that guy back when
and let me assure you he's not as smart
as i am
here
and then of course it was the case of
hurliland at one point shelling and
hagel had even talked about trying to
take care of her little in themselves
but they had agreed that this was just
not going to be possible given her
rather deteriorated state
on march 6 1830 hegel was invited as the
rector of the university by this time he
invited he'd become elected as the
president of the whole university to
attend a luncheon with the crown prince
his the crown prince's wife and other
members of the royal court there was
some discussion about members of the
court as to what they should talk about
with their celebrity philosopher and at
first the conversation seemed to stall
in order to break the ice princess
mariana the crown prince's wife asked
hegel about his old friend izakan
sinclair the princess was mariana of
hessen hamborg the little town of course
her hurdle and had been the librarian
her father had been the long gruff of
hess and homborg for whom sinclair had
been the minister sinclair in turn
remember had employed herland as the
librarian during hagel's stay in
frankfort her older sister augusta had
in fact in her youth had a great crush
on her lily
hegel suddenly came alive
his own memories of the heavy days in
frankfurt with his friend herland now
apparently living in the darkness of
mental illness in tubingen welled up but
he began to speak with great
spiritedness about the area itself
remembering the name of each small hill
that lay between frankfurt and hamburg
for de gera nowadays bought on board
uh hills that he'd so often walk with
sinclair and heralding
in her diary this is not their diary's
never been published in her diary the
princess noted in an almost christian
voice
at that point he began to speak of
herolin whom the world had forgotten of
his book hyperion which had constituted
an apple k for me on account of my
sister augusta's relations to them and i
found by the sounding of this name a
true joy a whole lost past went through
me it was a remembrance a remembrance
awakened as otherwise would be done
through a smell or melody or sound
the princess recalled her visit vivid
memories of seeing the sun coming
through the windows at window and seeing
the aperion herlan's novel bound in
green lying on the windowsill hagel
spoke of his now lost times with his old
friend
it was not the first time in berlin that
hagel had thought of his old at one time
dearest friend in fact hegel had been a
participant in an effort to get her
lillian's works published in berlin a
fastidious lieutenant in the prussian
army a man named johann heinrich east
had led the effort engaging
one of several prussian ministers
princess mariana and hagel himself who
had offered much advice and spoken of
the conversations that he and her leland
have pursued on the topics of hurling's
dramas but alas hegel had to tell the
east he personally had no manuscripts of
hurdles to offer for the audition and
finally in 1822 a new edition of
imperium was published followed by new
volumes of hurling's poetry in 1826.
hale never mentioned her lily in his
writings or his lectures
for hegel herland was seemed to have
been just an old friend he tended no
doubt to see hurling as someone who had
not completely worked through the common
revolutionary project that he and
schilling had begun as used in the
university
but it was clear even though never
spoken of him he'd never forgotten the
person to
who had the most influence on him and
had been his dearest friend for a moment
with princess mariana hegel was not
thinking of the present but was lost in
his youth again reliving in memory his
frankfurt days
hagel rose to a position of enormous
celebrity in berlin and i think one of
the things that's interesting is he
never abused this position in fact he
used it to help out young scholars he
was especially interested and always
always especially interested in helping
young people uh tirelessly working to
try and get them jobs in the university
settings and so on and also continuing
his efforts to reform things even
founded of popular magazine the
yearbooks for scientific criticism
together with edward gonz to more or
less popularize this kind of view
he
suffered from a gastrointestinal illness
and the last year of his life was really
one which
gave great difficulty he went to the
opera almost every night but then he
quit going out at night he was really
quite sick all the time
his wife noticed that he just wasn't his
old self again although he could be very
lively and very animated and his
lectures were now drawing people by the
hundreds sometimes by the thousands he
had become
as one person in berlin put it a
european phenomenon there was nothing
that happened in berlin either a new
building put up by an industrialist a
new opera that was being performed
or a new play being put on the stage but
all of berlin asks what does hagel think
about it here
on coming back there was a cholera
epidemic in berlin in 1831.
hegel
uh
gave some lectures on friday seemed to
be very weak went over to his good
friend zelter we always went over on
friday night and played cards usually
west with zelter and the royal stable
master and they'd always pick up a
fourth and so on until late at night
uh he got up on saturday morning thought
things were fine they invited some
friends over for dinner at noon he
started feeling very bad
by roughly eight o'clock he was feeling
very very bad and by the next day he was
having trouble breathing
and by five o'clock in the afternoon he
had died his cause of death was
pronounced as cholera although i think
it's quite easy to show this wasn't
cholera but something else
and this game was of course a great
shock to everyone in berlin hagel was
suddenly at the height of his fame the
height of his powers taken away from
everybody
the hegelian school quickly split into
the left and the right the hegelians
began arguing with each other about who
was the best propagator of hegel's
legacy
the prussian authorities themselves were
very unclear about what they thought
about all this
one of the strangest events that
happened was that shelling his old
friend shelling who had now grown really
quite conservative in his old age
ten years to the day of hagel's death
was given hegel's chair in berlin and
the official letter of appointment told
him that his duty was to stamp out the
dragon seed of hegelianism in berlin
sitting in the lecture that day were
three young men who had wanted to study
with hegel and they come to berlin to
get the spirit of hegelianism
the other was bakunen and the other was
friedrich engels
you might say that at that point history
was knocking on the door
here
hegel of course later became
appropriated by the reactionaries who
wanted to claim hegel as one of their
own there's a story about this which i
tell in the book exactly how this
happened
and strangely by roughly the 1870s and
1880s hegel had become seen as the
philosopher of prussian absolutism
the man who drank a glass of wine every
year to the storming of the bastille who
celebrated the french revolution who
tried his very best in fact to argue for
a representative government and as he
put it from power from below
and this new form of life would suddenly
become characterized so it looked like
for all history is in fact a stuffy
arrogant pompous you know little pet of
the state who had defended with all his
might the powers of the absolutist
prussian monarchy not true
sheldon died in 1854 he never was the
success that hagel was in fact the cuny
and kierkegaard and engels all were very
disappointed the lectures and left and
went elsewhere
here
since hagel's departure for yana
his oldest and dearest friends of his
youth hurling had been living in madness
in tubingen cared for by a carpenter and
his family
had even become by the 1820s a bit of a
literary tourist attraction and visitors
would seek him out talk with them and
often come away with a small piece of
rhyming poetry as a keepsake which her
lily would write for them on the spot
you could go and say after you talked
with hurdle and maybe bought him a drink
you could say could i have a point about
say springtime sure you know you write
these little rhyme couplets and sign
them usually scardanelli
here
but at the same point most likely in the
1820s
perhaps some perhaps around the same
time that hagel was having dinner with
the prussian royal family and wistfully
recounting with princess mariana his
time in frankfurt with her london
hurling himself
against the forces of his own madness
momentarily and for the very last time
regained his powers and composed his
last haunting piece of blank verse
alone among all of his poems it's
written in a woman's voice addressed to
him that of his love the long dead
cesaro gantard
it begins with the lines and prose
translation the german is much much
better
if from the distance that separated us
am i still recognizable to you the past
you share of my sufferings and it
recounts in loving detail the enchanted
days they shared in the gardens in
frankfurt the fields which they in which
they had met after hurling's dismissal
from the guitar household meetings of
course that hegel had helped to arrange
for the lovers
even the flowers that populated the
gardens of hamburg forte herrera and the
gantard house as the point progresses
hurled in sense of loss in the
alienation that had settled in over him
and the ensuing years of his madness and
isolation from his youthful friends
becomes palpable
and it concludes
those were beautiful days but they were
followed by a sorrowful twilight
that you are so alone in the beautiful
world you always asserted to me darling
that however something you don't know at
that point the point breaks off
the german literary scholar chris
christophe theodor schwab visited her
living shortly before his death on june
7 1843 hagel died in 1831. talked to him
about a number of things and he asked
him whether he ever thought of hegel
hurling answered of course he had
muttered something incomprehensible and
then noted simply we have to assume with
a smile on his face oh
the absolute thank you
[Applause]
terry will be more than happy to
entertain a few questions if you'd like
to
ask them
trevor could you speak a little bit
about uh hegel's writing style i believe
uh
holderland had uh something of an
influence in uh in
shaping that well of course hegel's
writing style in fact is one of his most
dubious legacies uh i think it's pretty
clear to say that there is probably no
more obscure philosopher than hegel uh
which is of course very striking because
when hegel wasn't writing philosophy in
fact was a brilliant
essayist when you read his writings all
throughout his life that aren't on
philosophy he has a great way of turning
phrases he has a sharp wit and so on
then when it comes to philosophy
it gets very
turgid
this is of course helped to fuel the
hegel legend of you know the pompous guy
with maybe maybe a gas bag and so on
one of the fee one of the things that
herolyn had developed already in the
late 1790s
was a view that modern life really
required something very different and
that it required therefore a new
language in fact hurling had gone so far
as to say that it required a new
mythology here a mythology of reason he
called it a new sensibility
and then for that new sensibility really
to take hold it was necessary for the
poets and the philosophers to invent a
new language because you couldn't rely
on just the old terms if you did that
you weren't really teaching people to
think for themselves and the goal of all
this was of course to become free
right to learn to perform without a net
right to really learn to live your own
life think for yourself and to that end
hegel then quite quite defiantly
throughout all his life even though he
was always told right that his writing
style was obscure said no i want to
write in this kind of way here something
again he picked up from herolyn i want
to write in this kind of way that forces
the reader to sit down and read the book
more closely here i don't want to give
them the easy way out and i want them to
be able to read the book so that they
learn to think for themselves in this
case
he followed this out in his own life for
example he pioneered the use of teaching
assistance the notion of teaching
assistants is actually one of the things
that we also owe to hegel and one of the
things that he liked to use teaching
assistants for was so that the students
could get out from under his thumb in
the lecture hall and discuss the matter
even disagree with him and so on uh so
this was in fact something that he
picked up from hurling although i think
it's i think we can probably say in
retrospect this is not uh one of his
best legacies and in fact not his most
successful effort in this attempt to
create
this new language now had we all been
talking hegelis for the last number of
years as in fact people in europe are
used to doing it wouldn't seem quite as
turgid as it does to
our more timid anglo-saxon souls over
here
i think schopenhauer kindest thing you
said about hagel was that he was a
blowhop yes
um
yeah arthur arthur schopenhauer of
course had um no good works to say about
hagel for him hegel was the just the
paradigm of everything that academic
life and philosophy should not be
and in fact a lot of the hegel legends
the bad ones all circulated about
schopenhauer
a front come from schopenhauer
schopenhauer tells the story that at his
thesis defense hegel morales inserted
himself into it asked some fairly stupid
questions that showed that he didn't
understand anything about modern science
and was shown up by all the scientists
and that you know just typical of hegel
of course one of things we do know
schopenhauer after getting his degree
nonetheless
defiantly offered lectures at the same
time as hegel uh this was quite an act
on the part of a 20-something youngster
to do
you must remember in those days
professors not only drew a salary you
also were paid by each individual
student for the lecture
you're good to buy a ticket to be able
to attend the lectures so to offer
lectures at the same time as another
professor
here was in effect to challenge his
means of livelihood so this was not
taken very lightly here
unfortunately nobody came to
schopenhauer's lectures and so he had to
give up and leave town rather in
disgrace and he never really forgave
hagel for that i
you know i was curious about this and i
went back and read the faculty minutes
in fact it turned out that hagel had
always been on the committee for sheldon
harry didn't barge in
uh and that hagel asked him some
questions having to do with the
relations between reasons and causes
that a zoology professor said oh we
don't make that distinction in zoology
and once hegel saw that schopenhauer
didn't get it at least as he thought he
should
he said well your answer is good enough
and although the other members of the
committee weren't in fact in favor hagel
passed schopenhauer on his dissertation
when schopenhauer offered his class at
the same time as hegel
the rest of faculty were outraged by
this they thought this was an insult to
a berlin professor and the young man
should be chastised perhaps even
punished and so on for this act and
hegel is on record in the faculty minute
saying
that's way out of line we shouldn't do
this you know we should be a lot more
tolerant about these kinds he is after
all very young and so on of course
hagel probably also knew nobody was
going to go anyway but nonetheless right
uh in fact hegel was again i think doing
the right thing there so
uh the relation between hegel and
schopenhauer is itself an interesting
piece of as it were real history as
opposed to the mythology that
schopenhauer has
given us over the years here
any other questions
yes i'm here to give a
biographical gloss on uh hegel's
situation when he wrote the philosophy
of wright
uh hegel wrote the philosophy of write
it was published in 1820 he had already
pretty well written it in 1818 1819
roughly uh when the
there's another myth about hegel that
says that he had composed the philosophy
of right
and then when 1820 rolled around and all
these anti-subversion laws came into
effect
that hegel then rewrote the whole book
in fact i think it's easy to show that
the manuscript was already impressed
before the subversion laws had come in
what happened was that the publication
date got put off because the censor had
to read the book
in this case it was during this period
that caravay and henning fontany were in
jail
here so the at this period there was a
period of intense political anxiety
here
hegel uh did not change the book and so
on and in fact published a book which in
many ways was going against exactly what
the conservatives in prussia were
arguing because in that book he argues
for
a representative government he argues
for a full set of rights that
individuals should be clothed with as it
were before they ever come into contact
with the state
uh and and so on so
none of the institutions that he argued
for were actually in place and of course
the striking point the book argued for a
constitution
which the king had promised which in
fact he never fulfilled
and that so that's that's
the biographical gloss is is in fact
that now
you're probably thinking of the preface
where hegel says
the rationals the actual and the actuals
the rational because at the time all of
hegel's
enemies in fact jumped on that and said
see hegel's become conservative hegel
thinks that what is is right and
everything that happens to exist in
prussia is is as it ought to be here
hegel was quite stung by this criticism
because
he made it quite clear he had thought
that by this this is not a little
technical by the phrase actual the
german term is vicklish that comes from
the term to be effective
what he meant by that was in fact that
it's no use proposing saying ideal moral
theory that can't be effective it's got
to have some grasp in people's lives
it's got to be able to move them so
constructing an ideal utopia is just
pointless
right for it to be it can't even be said
to be rational to construct an ideal
utopia unless you've got some way of
bringing it about
in 1824 uh the first edition of the
brockhouse encyclopedia there was an
entry on hegel
and from what we know hegel apparently
contributed quite a bit to the entry
although it was written by supposedly by
professor vent and leipzig she also was
one of hegel's friends
and in it it said people have attacked
hagel you know for being rather
conservative and saying that everything
it is is right nothing could be further
from the truth as he himself has said in
conversations i have never meant to
defend the interests of the powerful and
so on at the expense of other classes so
that's
hegel himself was rather stunned by the
reaction although
one has to say that
he could have put things a little more
differently
perhaps a little more
yeah
does that
give you another
any other questions
well thank you very much terry for
wedding our appetite and giving us some
reason to get the whole story by
buying eagle
thank you very much
[Applause]
terry pinkert is a philosophy professor
at georgetown university he's the author
or editor of five previous books
his biography of hegel is published by
cambridge university press
biography on book tv can be seen twice
every weekend here on c-span too